hey guys my name is Jess McDonald this
is gamespot knees and I have no
interesting interview today because it's
the boring old fifth of may oh well he
is gaming news remember that killzone
shadowfall lawsuit well what do you do
or don't the class-action suit where
Sony was being sued for allegedly
misleading consumers as to the quality
of their graphics is now over this all
started last summer when a man claimed
Sony Computer Entertainment
intentionally misled consumers 5 sang
shadow falls multiplayer mode featured
1080p graphics when in actuality it was
slightly less it was an upscaled 960 x
1080 resolution at 60fps the suit stated
that the graphics were blurry to the
point of distraction according to
courthouse news the case has now been
dismissed with prejudice which is legal
speak for permanently settlement terms
were not disclosed but what we can
assume is that everybody wasted a lot of
time and money case closed Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater 5 has officially been
unveiled for both current and last gen
on PlayStation and Xbox this marks the
first pro skater game since 2002
although you'd be forgiven for knowing
it was coming since Hawk did say a new
pro skater was on its way last November
Game Informer have reported that the
game will be developed by tony hawk ride
creator robolard oh and will feature
power-ups and the ability to shoot off
projectiles using a mission specific
ability the game will also include
offline and online modes and you can
design skate parks to share online if
you're into that skaters from past games
will be returning alongside some new
members and you can check out the full
list of those names on gamespot Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater fide is due out before
the end of the year on current-gen while
last gen versions will be available
later on finally the witcher 3 things
are happening and the studio is getting
ready to launch their drm free platform
god galaxy set a proactive rolling out
an open beta of the platform today and
as you can imagine its first major
release will be
the witcher 3 wild hunt on May nineteen
the platform will feature automatic
updates chat and achievements much like
Steam but God customers who want to play
offline will be able to do so with no
online activations required users are
now also able to download a standalone
drm-free backup of every game in their
library gorg have said of the platform
golf galaxy and its features are not
forced on you making it optional is the
best motivation for us to make it better
we want it to be so good that you'll
actually want to use it another way you
can get your hands on the witcher 3 is
for free so long as you buy a geforce
gtx 980 or gtx 970 graphics card nvidia
are delivering the witcher 3 and batman
arkham knight free of charge for anyone
picking up one of those two cards
personally I'm pretty keen for God
galaxy but let me know what you think
and if you reckon it's going to be any
good you can add against what we've got
use on mirrors edge coming in early 2016
and Sega's absent from e3 this year that
is everything I have for you today but
I'll have a bunch more stories tomorrow
so be sure to stop by then